family 4 está transmitiendo directamente
desde los exteriores del parlamento
peruano que ha citado a junta
extraordinaria de portavoces hoy domingo
a las 8 de la mañana para definir el
cambio de mando luís valdez
vicepresidente del legislativo ha dicho
que si manuel merino no renuncia
entonces ellos mismos se efectuarán los
cambios esto que quiere decir que la
actual directiva del parlamento va a
presentar su renuncia esto a su vez
automáticamente deja sin la presidencia
del parlamento a merino él perdería el
puesto de presidente del parlamento y a
su vez bloquearía su nombramiento como
presidente del perú seguidamente los
legisladores van a elegir entre los 130
congresistas a un representante que
pueda asumir el cargo francisco y
hablemos de la del estado en que se
encuentra el presidente merino porque
vimos que se difundió una foto reunido
con sus ministros que se sabe de él que
se sabe de sus planes
precisamente manuel merino no has dado
las caras en las últimas horas solamente
existe esta foto ha citado a una reunión
del consejo de ministros llamemos así a
los que quedan de su gabinete de
ministros para tomar medidas y emitir un
mensaje de los peruanos en todo el perú
le está pidiendo su renuncia y amnistía
internacional está exigiendo a las
autoridades peruanas que cese de la
represión hacia los manifestantes y al
sí mismo está exigiendo una
investigación y sanción a todas las
violaciones de derechos humanos que se
hayan producido durante las últimas
horas en las jornadas de protesta